la vie trépidante que nous venons dans
notre société moderne et cause pour
beaucoup de ce mal du siècle que nous
appelons le surmenage 1966 le surmenage
professionnel est déjà considéré comme
le mal du siècle
aujourd'hui on l'appelle le burn out ou
le syndrome d'épuisement professionnel
en france c'est dans les années 90 que
le personnel aidant travailleurs sociaux
enseignants médecins commencent à parler
ouvertement dans les médias du burn out
indiscutablement j'ai fait un épisode
d'épuisement professionnel
cela s'est traduit comment bien le avoir
peur de dénoncer une mauvaise nouvelle
en particulier si le pronostic était
très semble la sensation que j'étais le
plus bon à rien
perte de confiance en soi mais aussi
fatigue et stress font partie des
symptômes du burn out et à partir des
années 2000
la parole se libérait chez tous les
actifs paul lui à 26 ans il évolue dans
les métiers de la communication
son travail l'a épuisé il vient de se
faire interner vrai que j'arrête avec je
lève le pied
c'est un travail au moins un épuisement
professionnel qui pousse aussi parfois
des situations extrêmes j'avais plus
d'identité jeu je voulais mourir je
n'existais plus si les cas de burn out
semblent se multiplier en france les
statistiques sur le sujet reste flou et
rare en 2014
le cabinet technologia spécialisé dans
la prévention des risques estimés à 3,2
millions le nombre de français au bord
du burn out contre trente mille pour
l'institut national de veille sanitaire
une fourchette large qui en dit long sur
la difficulté de mesurer les troubles
psychiques prenant le temps de définir
tous les tableaux psychique et pas que
le bernard sans quoi nous allons aboutir
aux mêmes concepts poubelles que pour le
harcèlement aujourd'hui le burn out
n'est toujours pas reconnue comme une
maladie professionnelle
un combat que mène pourtant de nombreux
parlementaires depuis quelques années en
le député ps benoît hamon déposé trois
amendements à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui vous fait une dépression
liée à votre travail c'est l'assurance
maladie qui paye je souhaite qu'une
dépression liée au travail soit reconnu
comme lié au travail que ce soit la
branche accidents du travail qui paye
les propositions de benoît hamon
resteront vaines tout comme celle des
députés la france insoumise rejeté à
l'assemblée en février 2018 depuis l'
oms a reconnu le burn out comme un
phénomène lié au travail mais toujours
pas comme une maladie professionnelle
[Musique]
oh